[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sur la chaussée elles sont maintenant
presque aussi visibles que les iconiques
taxi jambes depuis quelques mois dans la
jungle new-yorkaise les terrasses ont
poussé comme des champignons
c'est une ville qui est assez dur au
quotidien donc c'est vrai que le côté
social de la restauration c'est très
important à niort avec les mesures de
confinement
la terrasse est devenu le meilleur outil
de lionel brument pour son restaurant de
blocs les haines puisse accueillir des
clients eux mêmes quelques jours après
la pire tempête de neige qu'ait connu
new york 1 5 1 nous on a dû construire
une cabane avec tout ce qui ce qui va
derrière ça de toute l'électricité avec
le chauffage on sait les factures
évidemment délirante puisque on est allé
le chauffage est allumée toute la
journée
aujourd'hui il fait très froid donc ça
coûte beaucoup d'argent alors par contre
on a rajouté une taxe kovy de taxes vous
pouvez pas sûr mais juste en faisant de
la vente à emporter
ça c'est impossible les loyers sont
tellement excessifs pour pouvoir
s'installer dans une rue du village
le restaurant de gérald barthélémy a dû
respecter plusieurs normes l'air
extérieur doit obligatoirement circuler
et la capacité d'occupation doit être
ajustée en fonction du degré d'aération
un mur rempli de sable permet de
protéger le client d'un éventuel
accident qu'après on remontait tout à
structure en investissement tout près de
40000 dollars
c'est sur ces des cours mais c'est ça ou
malheureusement vous vous perdez tout
comme des dizaines de milliers d'autres
à travers le pays
l'établissement voisin de celui de
gérald barthélémy a fermé ses portes
pour survivre les restaurateurs se sont
donc rués sur les permis qui autorise
l'installation de tables sur la chaussée
en ce moment on compte plus de 10000
terrasse dans les métropoles américaines
dix fois plus qu'en temps normal et
signe de leur popularité
le maire a annoncé qu'elle était là pour
rester c'est ce que nous avons eu deux
clients sur cette panne qui cherchent en
priorité les espaces chauffer le repas
en terrasse et la manière de fuir les
zones à new york on veut s'assurer que
la pandémie qui a durement frappé la
ville ne laisse pas les cicatrices au
delà des terrasses plusieurs autres
projets sont donc évoqué pour améliorer
l'environnement urbain les tours autour
de nous la sont presque vides
elles sont à 10 15 20 % d'occupation les
employés sont chez eux est la plus
grande énigme des mois à venir une fois
que le vaccin ne l'aura aidé à conquérir
le virus c'est est ce que les gens vont
revenir
jérôme barde travail à la revitalisation
de la 5ème avenue
le secteur qui comme bien d'autres à
travers le monde cherche à se renouveler
depuis le début de la pandémie la très
dense new york a perdu de son
attractivité
des milliers de résidents ont choisi de
la quitter qu'on profite de la banlieue
il faut réinventer la ville pour qu'elle
soit plus piétonne qu'elle favorise le
fait que les gens puissent rester dehors
plus longtemps cela peut être par des
terrasses pour les restaurants mais ça
peut être aussi par des petits parcs par
des sièges par toutes sortes de choses
mais il ya une véritable réflexion sur
comment rendre la ville plus
accueillante aux gens dans la prétendue
monde
pour offrir plus d'espacé vert l'état
annoncé la prolongation de la high line
ses promenades urbaines construite sur
une ancienne voie ferrée puis avec
l'augmentation du nombre de vélos sur
les routes depuis le début de la
pandémie le pont de brooklyn aura sa
piste cyclable dédié la pandémie aura
contribué à ce que le paysage new
yorkais soit remodelé qui est nouveau
avec les années les crises ont forcé la
ville à se réinventer
c'est après une épidémie de choléra que
le parc le plus célèbre de new york a
été créé ça faisait partie des grands
parcs qui ont été créés pour permettre
aux gens d'échapper aux puces qui était
malade et prendre de l'air trottoirs
espaces de stationnement avec la
multiplication des terrasses les rues de
new york sont évidemment appelé à
changer sur le plan physique
le restaurateur gerald par télé me entre
bois aussi des retombées économiques
forcément notre venue va augmenter quand
on peut espérer qu'un jour cette
pandémie s'arrête et qu'on puisse
retourner à une capacité de 100 % à
l'intérieur donc après forcément il ya
plus de taxes qui est rentré forcément
plus de revenus aussi pour pour l'état
de new york
bien sûr la politique encadrant les
terrasses pourrait être révisé mais
après une telle avant goût revenir en
arrière pourrait être difficile à avaler
j'aimerais pas être le maire qui va dire
non on arrête ça parce que ce niveau à
voir ne va pas être très populaire
[Musique]